hey how's it going hey
wait what is y'all Club jump rope hold
on you're telling me you've never heard
of Club jump rope no yeah fair enough
we're pretty new we're y'all's newest
club sports we do performances
competitions it's a good workout but
mostly it's just a fun group of people
to hang out with
you know this sounds like something I'd
be interested in oh awesome
I'll warn you though I haven't done this
since elementary school
[Music]
that's totally fine we'll teach you
everything don't worry about it just
follow along
[Music]
oh my God
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hey what's Yale Club jump rope
you've never heard of yell Club jump
rope
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign